Jamie was it you that was telling me
yesterday about the guy who's the EMT
who sees tell me tell me what you told
me he said he said he was listening to
the podcast who did with Lewis J Gomez
about people getting head injuries and
he has been doing I believe for like 15
years or so like doesn't do it every
single day because you don't work every
single day but on a three day basis or
so every day he works he sees at least
one person dead from a head injury
whether it's an elderly person there
slipped on ice something people fall and
hit their heads oh yeah like that's why
please folks if you're listening to me
and you want to punch somebody and knock
them out please don't do it just go to a
gym get your frustrations out don't
fight on the street you could kill
somebody or you can get killed even
accidentally even if you really don't
hate the guy that much you punch him in
the face go unconscious their head hits
the ground people die all the time you
mean I've told the story about when
Kevin James used to work as a bouncer in
Long Island a guy that he was working
with punched a guy and killed him or
Hillary yeah Kevin Kevin wasn't there
but he knew the guy and the guy
accidentally killed a drunk guy drunk I
was coming at him he punched him I guess
I don't know the whole story but that
shit happens all the time I've seen guys
and it's not about the punch though it's
about when they hit their head you're
getting hit by the world yeah think
about that think of the world just drop
on your head that's what it's like your
body mass bouncing off a completely
especially concrete there's no give so
your head just o'clock it sounds
horrible why listen to someone's head
bounced off concrete is one of the
scariest fucking sounds oh it's horrible
even if you do it to somebody and you
wanted to hurt them when you hear their
head bounced off concrete you're like oh
shit like that's not as simple as like
you punched them you punched them and
then you know whatever they weigh 190
pounds with all the mass of grass all
their mass and gravity pulling them
towards the ground with nothing slowing
it down but meat and head bang bone I
shoulder that reminds me when I was 10
years old I was sitting on the curb and
this is the first time I saw death in
real life from a head injury I was
sitting with my friend on the curb and a
guy was driving a motorcycle and he was
speeding up and down the street and
right on iris wood in Houston
hexxus he's flying down a car pulls out
and he hits it backed in they didn't
wear helmets so he literally flew up in
the air and landed about 20 feet from us
his head hit first oh and exploded like
a watermelon and this is like I was 10
years old watching this so the next
morning you know the police come my
parents gave me to tell me don't look at
it to put III go out there the next day
it's just blood stains everywhere and
his wife is picking up his hair that's
stuck to the concrete and I remember
it's so vividly I was next door neighbor
was Eric and we were sitting on the curb
watching this lady pick up her husband's
hair that was stuck in and that's the
first time I ever saw death and it was
and it was a gnarly death - it was like
that phases of death stuff like it was
bad it was bad I never rode a motorcycle
because of that yeah there's no there's
not a lot of reasons to ride a
motorcycle other than that's awesome
yeah the fucking danger
I took motorcycle safety classes and
then two of my friends wiped out one of
them got hit by a car and one of them
fell going around a corner and fucked
his shoulder up
i I after that accident probably about
six years later you know when three
wheelers would be back yeah and my
friends same friend that was on a car we
were three willing and and where I grew
up there was bunch of ditches so we're
going and he thought he could go down in
the ditch and come up the other side but
I think he forgot that his flat on the
bottom of real ditches so literally
we're going and we hit the bottom and I
flew up and literally half my face was
like just wrecked I was in a hospital
and it's and we didn't have helmets at
that tars and because we're young and
dumb and just wanted to like stupid
stupid